Hello everyone. Today we're going to
create a lightning burst effect. It's a
relatively simple effect like the one we
see in the level. It can be combined
with other lightning strike or arc
effects. In future videos, we'll
assemble them into a complete effect. So
let's get started.
>> [music]
>> To create this effect, we only need
three textures. Actually, just this one
is enough. The other two represent
[music] an alternative method which will
also demonstrate. First, create a new
material.
Set its blend mode to additive, lighting
model to unlit, and enable two-sided.
[music]
The lightning texture we're using is
provided by Epic. You can download it
for free on my Patreon. Put all three
textures into the material. Let's start
with the simplest method using the sub
UV texture. Add flipbook function and
particle random value node.
It generates a random value between zero
and [music] one for each Niagara
particle. Connect it to the animation
phase input, then connect the texture
UVs accordingly. This allows the four
sub textures [music] to be displayed
randomly producing a random shape.
Finally, multiply it by the particle
[music] color.
As we can see, by adjusting the
parameters, it randomly switches between
zero and one to control different
shapes. Very simple, and we can add
other effects as well. Let's make it in
the second method.
Now we use the other two textures. Each
channel of this texture represents a
different lightning shape.
And the other texture is a mask for each
channel. So what we need to do is to use
UV coordinates to control displaying
only one texture channel at a time.
This allows us to achieve a flipbook
like effect.
We still need the particle random value
node. First, multiply the mask texture
by four, apply a floor, add 0.5,
>> [music]
>> then multiply by 0.25.
Yes, this looks similar to the method
for creating a pixelated texture.
However, for this mask texture, it is
used to display only one quadrant of the
mask texture different colors. Adding
0.5 is to shift the pivot point to the
center of each subregion.
Next, multiply the RGBA channels of this
mask with the RGBA channels of the
original texture.
Use particle random value again to
control the random shape. Yes, we'll see
it switch between different shapes.
However, the RGB channels of the
particle color cannot be directly
multiplied with the RGBA channels of the
texture, and we only need the four
lightning shapes. So use a breakout
float node to split the four channels,
then add them together.
Now they are just various shapes with no
channel distinction.
Finally, [music] multiply the result by
the alpha of the particle color.
Add a power [music] to control lightning
shapes. Since we're using the additive
blend mode, we don't need to handle
opacity separately.
Simply add a depth fade node to create a
soft edge transition between the
lightning [music] and static meshes.
We can also add distortion to the
lightning shape as we've done before.
Use a noise texture,
>> [music]
>> multiply it by a mask that expands over
time. This creates a burst effect where
the lightning spreads outward from a
point. Use particle relative time to
drive it. The value is zero when the
particle spawns and approaches one near
the end of its lifetime. With lerp and
diamond gradient, this gives a gradual
expansion from dark to bright.
Let's disconnect particle relative time
to demonstrate this effect.
Yes, a nice diffusion effect is achieved
using the basic node.
All right, this is how the material is
created. Now let's set up the Niagara
system.
In the sprite renderer, replace the
material with the one we just created.
In the emitter state, set the life cycle
to self, loop behavior to once, duration
to 0.3 seconds.
Set spawn burst [music] count to five
and spawn rate to 20.
In initialize particle, [music] set
lifetime mode to random between 0.1 and
0.15 [music] seconds. Color can be
controlled by user parameter. For now,
set it to a blue or purple.
Sprite size is 350 to 600.
Oh, the noise distortion intensity is
too high. Let's reduce it by multiplying
by 0.1.
Yes, it looks much better now.
Set sprite rotation to random.
In particle update, add scale color and
scale sprite size.
>> [music]
>> Well, its color didn't turn. Let's take
a look at the material.
All right, we only connected [music] the
R channel here. It should be connected
to the RGB channel. Just a small
oversight. Okay, we get purple.
For sprite size, start at one and end at
1.5 creating a gradual enlargement.
That's a simple lightning burst effect.
Now duplicate it to create a brighter
version.
This one needs fewer particles. Set
spawn rate to five.
Lifetime shorter, 0.05
to 0.1 seconds.
And make the size a bit larger. Color
should be brighter.
View it in isolation. It's bright and
short-lived. The previous version has a
slightly longer spawn duration and
lifetime. Okay, this is a very simple
lightning burst effect. In upcoming
videos, we'll combine it with the
lightning strike effect we made earlier
to form a complete lightning effect.
That's all for this video. Hope you
enjoyed it. Bye.